um the prime minister's um about speak
let's go straight to commons to pmq they
will shortly be providing a further
package of military support to ukraine
this will include lethal aid in the form
of defensive weapons and non-lethal aid
mr speaker i'm sure the whole house
will want to join me in congratulating
team gb's curling teams for winning gold
and silver medals at the winter olympics
and mr speaker i know
that members across the house will want
to offer condolences
to the family and friends of our former
colleague sir richard shepard who sadly
died earlier this week he served as the
mp for aldridge brown hills for 36 years
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today david johnson thank you mr speaker
by 2027 dead cot in my constituency will
be 42 larger than it was a decade
earlier wantage and grove will be 59
larger there are thousands more houses
going in wallingford farringdon and all
the villages i represent
and not a single new gp surgery
does my honorable friend agree that
where we build new houses we have to
build new infrastructure
so that people can still access the
services they need
prime minister yes of course my
honorable friend is right mr speaker and
that's why we're making record
investments uh in the nhs and and in
schools and roads as we can mr speaker
thanks to the strong growth in our
economy and i'll make sure that he gets
a meeting with the relevant minister to
discuss his immediate local concerns we
now come to the leader of the opposition
uh thank you mr speaker can i join with
the comments of the prime minister in
relation to richard shepard
mr speaker we all want to deter
aggression in europe
we're not dealing with breakaway
republics putin is not a peacekeeper a
sovereign nation has been invaded
the prime minister promised that in the
event of an invasion he would unleash a
full package of sanctions
if not now
then when
prime minister mr speaker as i said the
uk has been out in uh front uh in
offering military support to ukraine and
i'm grateful for what he said yesterday
about the need uh to make sure that we
uh keep ammunition in reserve for what
could be a protracted struggle over this
issue but they've been it has been in no
doubt about the extent of the package
that was already been uh set out
yesterday and and what we are already
doing because mr speaker i don't think
people quite realize uh that the uk
is out in front we've sanctioned 275
individuals already uh yesterday we
announced measures uh the place banks
were 37 billion pounds were 37 billion
pounds under sanctions in addition to
more oligarchs and mr speaker there is
more to come and we will be we will be
stopping russia we will be stopping
russia from raising sovereign debt
stopping companies russian companies
from raising money and stopping russian
uh russian companies as i said yesterday
even clearing uh in sterling and dollars
on on international markets uh mr
speaker that will hit putin where it
hurts but it is absolutely vital that
after this first barrage we work in
lockstep with friends and allies around
the world and we squeeze him
simultaneously we squeeze him
simultaneously in london in paris in new
york at the same time unity mr speaker
is absolutely vital
i hear what the prime minister says
about sequencing and about further
sanctions
but there's already been an invasion
and there's clearly concern across the
house that his strategy i accept
unintentionally could send the wrong
message
so
so if the prime minister
if the prime minister
if the prime minister now brings forth
his full package of sanctions including
excluding russia from financial
mechanisms like swift and a ban on
trading in russian sovereign debt he
will have the full support of the house
will he do so minister uh i'm grateful
mr speaker i think i think yesterday and
i'm grateful by the way uh for the
general support uh that the opposition
have given uh not just to our economic
sanctions but also uh to the package of
military support which will as i've said
intensify what we want to see mr speaker
is de-escalation uh by vladimir putin
there's still there's still hope that he
will uh that he will see sense uh but we
will we are ready uh very rapidly to
escalate our sanctions as i have as i
have as i have set out and under the
measures that uh this house has already
approved and uh that we can now target
mr speaker any russian uh entity any
russian individual we can already target
not just the breakaway republics uh the
so-called the so-called breakaway
republics in the oblasts of uh donetsk
and luganz we can target members of the
duma who voted to recognize them this is
the most far-reaching piece of
legislation of its kind and i'm glad
that it has his support
it does have my support and if it's used
we will support it
we must also do more to defeat putin's
campaign of lies and disinformation
russia today is his personal propaganda
tool
i can see no reason why it should be
allowed to continue to broadcast in this
country
so will the prime minister now ask ofcom
to review his license
prime minister mr speaker i believe that
my right honourable friend the secretary
of state for culture media sport has
already uh asked ofcom to review uh that
matter but
but what i will say mr speaker is that
is that we live in a in a democracy mr
speaker and we live in a a country that
believes in in free speech and uh i
think it's important that we should
leave it up to ofcom rather than to
politicians to decide which media
organizations to ban that's what russia
does
[Music]
[Applause]
the request was for a review and i'm
very glad to hear that that review is
now happening and i'm not
i'm mr speaker i'm not going to be
deflected from the unity that this house
needs just at the moment
at the week at the week
at the weekend the prime minister said
that if russia invades ukraine he will
open up the matriasca dolls of
russian-owned companies and
russian-owned entities to find the
ultimate beneficiaries within
well russia has invaded
and it's time to act
if the prime minister's brings forward
the required legislation to do this he
will have labour support
so will he commit to do so in the coming
days yes administer
mr speaker we are we're as i as i said
uh bringing forward in the next wave of
sanctions measures that will stop all
russian banks all oligarchs all uh
russian individuals raising money on uh
on london uh markets and uh we are also
accelerating uh mr speaker the economic
crime bill which will enable us in the
uk to peel back the
in the next session mr speaker to peel
back the facade to peel back the facade
of beneficial ownership of property in
in the uk and of companies it's gone on
for far too long we are going to tackle
it under this government uh mr speaker
uh but on all these measures i think it
is very very important uh that the house
remembers they are more effective when
all financial centers move forward
together and that is that is what the uk
has been organizing
[Applause]
mr speaker i think i heard the promise
to say that the economic tribal will be
in the next session
i i hope i misheard that
but i can assure him if he brings it
forward in this session in coming days
it will have our support there's no
reason to delay this
let me also turn to the elections bill
as it stands the bill would allow
unfitted donations from overseas to be
made to uk political parties
from shell companies and individuals
with no connections to the uk
labor has proposed amendments to protect
our democracy from the flood of foreign
money drowning our politics
we can all now see how serious this is
[Music]
so will the prime minister now change
course and support these measures in the
house of lords
mr speaker we have very tough laws tough
rules in this country uh to stop foreign
donations uh we don't accept we don't
accept foreign uh donations you have to
be on the on the register of the uk
electoral register to give to uk
political party and uh before he starts
chucking it around mr speaker i just
remind him he's the largest single
corporate donation uh to the labour
party he came from a member of the
chinese communist party
[Music]
no mr speaker
at this moment as the house agreed
yesterday we have to stand united
i know the prime minister
the prime minister did not agree to
change the elections bill
i think that's a mistake
and i ask him to take it away and look
at it again those amendments in the laws
putin has invaded a sovereign european
nation
he has attacked because he fears
openness and democracy and because he
knows that given a choice people will
not choose to live under erratic violent
rule
he seeks division
we must stay united
he hopes for inaction
so we must take a stand
he believes that we're too corrupted to
do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong
and i believe that we can
so will the prime minister work across
the house
to ensure that this is the end of the
era of oligarch impunity
by saying that this house and this
country will no longer be homes for
their loot
mr speaker i don't think any government
could conceivably be doing more to root
out corrupt russian money and that is
and that is what uh that is what we are
going to do and i think we can be proud
of what we've already done and the
measures that we have set up
i must speak i'm genuinely grateful uh
for the tone of his last question and
for the support and for the support he
has given and he is right that it is
absolutely vital that we in the uk
should stand united and people around
the world can see that the uk was the
first to call out what president putin
was doing uh in uh ukraine uh we've been
instrumental in bringing the world
together the western world together in
lockstep to deal with the uh the problem
uh to bring together the economic
package of sanctions that i that i have
set out and mr speaker there is still
time for president putin as i've said to
de-escalate
but what is at stake being absolutely no
doubt is not just the democracy of
ukraine but the principle of democracy
around the world and that is why the
unity of this house is so important
today and it is absolutely vital that
the united kingdom stands uh together
against aggression in ukraine and i am
grateful for the
broad support that we've had today from
the leader of the opposition
[Music]
thank you mr speaker following last
week's q a at the shepler village
association and after receiving a huge
number of complaints from constituents
it is clear that speeding is a major
problem not just in shepley but across
all parts of june murfield kurt burton
and denver dale
rather than action being taken after
people have been killed or seriously
injured in collisions
would my right honorable friend agree
with me that prevention is better than
the cure and that the department for
transport circular 2007 needs a long
overdue review
prime minister uh yes mr speaker look i
i i thank him i share his passion on
this issue as a as a cyclist and i do
think that uh we need to crack down on
uh speeding which does play a a role in
uh excessive uh deaths on our on our
roads and the department of transport is
updating uh the circular that he uh that
he mentions uh on the use of speed and
red light cameras and uh i'd urge him to
get in touch with my rather friend the
secretary's state
leader of the smp in blackford
thank you mr speaker yesterday this side
of the house made clear that the snp
stands united against the russian
invasion of ukraine and this needs to be
included with tougher and stronger
sanctions
but as the chair of the foreign affairs
select committee rightly said
we shouldn't be waiting for russia to
attack others to clean up the corruption
and russian money which has been fueling
in the uk
under the tories
a sewer of dirty russian money has been
allowed to run through london for years
i went to the prime minister the then
foreign secretary in 2017 and i raised
the issue of limited partnerships 113 of
which have been used to move
20.8
billion dollars out of russian banks
corruption on an industrial scale
why did the prime minister do nothing
back then
and why is he still doing nothing now
prime minister
mr speaker that i i'm grateful tim he's
you know he's uh i think that
he was right to come to me then and i've
always enjoyed uh talking to him as i've
told him many times i think he's right
on on the issue we do need to stop
corrupt russian money in london and
every other financial capital that's why
we've already taken uh the steps that we
we have taken but we are going much
further to uncloak the the true owners
of russian companies and russian
properties uh in this country and uh and
high time mr speaker no country is doing
more than the uk to tackle this issue
mr speaker that meeting was five years
ago and i offered to work with the prime
minister five years ago
and nothing has happened
the truth is
that russian oligarchs who give the
right people in power a golden handshake
have been welcomed into london for years
their activities weren't stopped
they were encouraged
and plenty of these golden handshakes
just so happened to find their way into
the coffers of the conservative party
mr speaker
2.3 million pounds in fact
since the prime minister took office a
leading american think tank has publicly
raised concerns and i quote about the
close ties between russian money and the
united kingdom's ruling conservative
party are a block to stronger sanctions
how can our allies
trust this prime minister
to clean up dirty russian money in the
uk but he won't even clean up his own
political party will he finally commit
finally commit to giving up the 2.3
million his party has raised in from
russian oligarchs prime minister mr
speaker i i just think it's very
important for the house to understand uh
we do not raise money from russian
oligarchs uh people who people who give
money to this to this to this they they
are they we raise money uh from people
who are registered to vote on the uk
register of interest and that is that is
how that is how we do it mr speaker and
i think i think his indignation uh his
indignation is i'm afraid uh a bit much
coming from uh coming from somebody uh
whose very own alex salmond is a leading
a leading presenter a leading presenter
on as far as i know on russia today
which the leader of the opposition has
just called on this country to back
so bill william
[Music]
the riverway
pollution flooding hospital building and
the wider environment are all important
to my right honourable friend so will he
meet me to discuss the future of the
environment agency
oh prime minister well i'm always happy
to to meet my uh my my honorable friend
and i congratulate him on his on his
recent uh uh elevation but mr speaker i
i also i also must say that i think the
environment agency uh faces many
challenges and does an outstanding job
of building flood defenses uh 314 000
homes are better protected than since
2015 and we continue to invest massively
uh to help them but i'm always always
happy to meet him
thank you mr speaker yesterday when i
asked the prime minister about russian
meddling in uk elections he looked very
shifty before claiming he wasn't aware
of any
yet
when he was
[Applause]
when he was foreign secretary
in 2017
in a joint press conference with the
russian foreign minister when lafrov
claimed there was no evidence that
russia had interfered in uk elections in
any way the now prime minister corrected
him by saying there was no evidence of
successful interference so can the prime
minister tell us what evidence he has
seen of unsuccessful interference
has he actually read the russia report
which is very clear that there is
credible evidence of interference
and
[Applause]
and given that as his defense secretary
said earlier this week
information is as powerful as any tank
can he explain why he's turning a blind
eye
to allegations of russian
disruption
[Applause]
i hope you're coming to the end of the
question i do need to
landlord the speaker i could be a lot
faster if i wasn't being barrett
[Applause]
i think the challenge is that i do want
to get the front benches moving quickly
we've got to get speed into it so i'm
sure it's the end now
given that as his defense secretary said
earlier this week that information is as
powerful as anytime
can he explain why he is turning a blind
eye to allegations of russian disruption
why is he playing fast and loose
prime minister
i repeat what i told her ages ago if i
think i've got it right i've seen
absolutely no evidence of successful
russian uh in interference in any of our
uh any of any election or any electoral
event mr speaker
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and i welcome the
steps the government is taking to help
hard-working families in orpington this
year with their energy bills and the
majority of people will receive at least
350 pounds of support but can my honor
friend confirm that even those not
eligible for the council tax rebate will
still receive additional support thanks
to discretionary funding set aside for
local authorities
prime minister uh my older friend is
absolutely right and uh i can tell him
that the people of walpington and
elsewhere uh will receive support if
if they don't qualify for the council
tax uh rebate from the 144 a million
pound fund that he rightly mentions
how does the prime minister think it
looks when we're in a cost of living
crisis with our constituents struggling
to put food on the table or coats um on
their kids backs when the members of his
cabinet are throwing their toys out of
the pram because they want to eat freud
and wear
fury there's a figure we are tackling uh
the cost of living crisis which is
caused by a global uh inflation spike uh
with everything we can do uh and i i
thank them my right old friend the
chancellor in particular of what he's
doing to abate the cost of energy
lifting the living wage uh by the
biggest ever amount
helping people on universal credit mr
speaker and the single best thing that
we've done on the cost of living mr
speaker is making sure that we've got
millions more people into work 430 000
more in employment now than there were
before the pandemic began that's how
we're tackling the cost of living mr
speaker we'll get on with it thank you
buddy
thank you mr speaker last month i held a
careers fair at the woodlands campus of
soleil college
it trains apprentices for the automotive
construction and aviation industry these
apprentices are talented and hardworking
and this is why flybe has chosen
birmingham airport in my constituency as
their national headquarters
will the prime minister take up my
invitation to visit solihull college and
meet these wonderful apprentices and
then also visit birmingham airport to
see how the aviation industry is
recovering from the pandemic
uh mr speaker i'm only to happy thrilled
to visit
my honourable friend and mary den at any
time
jose
uh mr speaker the
member for sherwood is currently under
investigation for islamophobia following
accusations he told a fellow mp that her
being a muslim was making colleagues
uncomfortable
how did the government punish this
behavior with a promotion that puts the
accused member in charge of the
complaints procedure
and
is no stranger to derogatory remarks
about muslim women
so let me
order let me
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker i have just come
from a meeting with the london pedicab
operators association
child sport for london department of
transport
where sadly the
honourable member for christchurch
confirmed that on friday he will be
objecting once again to my pedicabs
london bill which means it will fall
does my little friend agree with me that
it is time that we legislated for
pedicabs to make sure that they are safe
for women and girls to use
ourselves of
the dodgy fairs and that
that the noise that they create
will he work with me to
legislate and regulate pedicabs once
when i was mayor of london i always
yearned to be in a position uh to put
this through parliament uh and now i am
and i'm i'm very grateful to her we will
make sure that we give uh parliamentary
time
to make this possible i think it will be
a boon
for cyclists it will be a boon mr
speaker for taxi drivers and it's high
time we did it
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker we have a
humanitarian crisis of food poverty in
all the constituencies represented in
this house
we've got more food banks than
mcdonald's and people now face starving
or freezing in their homes at this very
moment
because of terrific cost of living
crisis but because of political choices
that have been made by these governments
in 2015 the government signed up to
delivering the 2030 sustainable
development goals domestically including
ending hunger
can the prime minister
tell me who
and what department is responsible for
delivering this goal to end hunger
domestically
and can he send me a copy of the plan to
deliver it
mr speaker the whole of government is
engaged in that in that campaign and to
that end uh we expanded free school
meals uh for five to seven-year-olds
which helps 1.3 million children we
boosted the healthy start vouchers by a
third mr speaker and of course there's a
holiday food and activities uh program
uh that continues to run the 200 million
pound fund but the best thing that we uh
we can do as a country as a society is
keep going uh with our uh plan for
economic growth uh with higher wage
higher skilled jobs uh putting bread on
the food our bread on the table of
families up and down this country
thank you mr speaker speciality steals
is an important steel works in
stocksbridge in my constituency produces
high quality steel and it's provided
high value jobs for generations but
sadly following the collapse of cell
capital the parent company liberty has
faced financial uncertainty for some
time threatening the business and
thousands of jobs so does my right
honourable friend agree with me that the
steel industry sits at the heart of our
leveling up agenda and will he commit to
looking at all options to support the
business through this period of
uncertainty as the government has done
so effectively for forge masters and
british students
prime minister i i thank her very much
and i thank her for everything she does
to
deter champion steel uh and i i i think
she's right i think that it is of
strategic importance for our country and
we've got to look at ways in which we
can help the steel industry uh to have
access to uh cheaper low-carbon energy
and this government will do everything
we can uh to ensure that that happens uh
but we provide so far we've provided
over 600 million pounds since 2013 to
help with the cost of energy and uh and
we have uh we've reduced we've also put
in a 350 million pound uh
industrial energy transformation fund
but i want to stress to the house that
that alone uh will not be enough as we
transition uh to a low carbon future i
think that hydrocarbons must also have
their place
thank you mr speaker unpaid family
carers are treated appallingly by this
government i'm not talking about paid
care staff in care homes but people who
provide care unpaid for family members
while food and energy costs skyrocket
carer's allowance is increasing in april
by only two pounds to a miserly 69
pounds a week but this insulting amount
will now be more than swallowed up by
paying the 2.50 cost of a single lateral
flow test so that carers can keep the
person they care for safe how can the
prime minister justify this tax on care
[Applause]
i i thank her very very much and i think
that the whole house understands uh the
pressures on on carers and the the
immense amount uh that they contribute
uh to our society and uh we are doing
our best to support people throughout
our our country uh we can't i think the
because also understands that we can't
uh indefinitely support uh free uh for
universal uh free testing uh what we are
doing what we are doing is uh upgrading
the the carers allowance and of course
uh carers are also entitled uh to the
increases that we're putting through in
universal credit
thank you very much mr speaker can i
follow up my right honourable friend
statement on monday on removing the
covered restrictions i welcome the
support the further support for the is
suppressed will he ensure the nhs
reviews the system for identifying the
most vulnerable as i think some who are
at risk are in danger of being missed
for example those with blood cancers and
will he then ensure that the relevant
testing and antibody antiviral drugs
would be readily available alongside
boosters for the immune suppressed but
also for their carers
yes uh he's making a very important
point about the uh about the immuno uh
suppressed and and the need to identify
them correctly uh we currently think
there are 1.3 million yes of course uh
they will have access not only to
testing but also uh to vaccines to
boosters and priority access for new uh
therapeutics and antivirals so i'm
terrible
thank you mr speaker
last october a promising young
footballer in my alford south
constituency called cameron khalid he
was a former winner of chelsea fc's
asian star scheme and played for the
famous senrab fc in wants did he on his
way home to see his mum after finishing
at the gym and he was stabbed 24 times
murdered just yards from his front door
one of the perpetrators alleged
perpetrators was as young as 15
so mr speaker i would hope that the
prime minister would agree with me that
far more needs to be done to stamp out
the scourge of knife crime including
addressing the underlying causes already
agreed to meet me and cameron's mother
samina who said that losing her 18 year
old son has after a void in her heart
forever
discuss what more can be done to make
our streets safer ensure that other
families don't ever have to suffer this
heartbreaking loss
prime minister
mr speaker i i must say that i i totally
uh agree with i share his feelings about
the his constituents and and the tragedy
and the tragic loss of of uh the the
family concerned and we must crack down
uh more on knife crime it's one of the
reasons we're putting more police out on
the uh on the streets uh and it's also
why we're rounding up the county lines
drugs gangs and we've done we've run and
i think they played a big part in this
uh sadly we've done two thousand uh so
far uh there is more to do that's why
we're recruiting many more police and
giving them the powers they need to come
down hard on these gangs andy carter
thank you very much mr speaker the
government's commitment of 25 million
pounds for a new electric bus fleet in
warrington will have a transformational
effect on public transport across
warrington
does the prime minister agree with me
that the right way to spend that 25
million is by buying british-made buses
supporting highly skilled jobs
manufacturing jobs right across the
united kingdom
uh yes uh mr speaker i want to thank my
honorable friend who is a great champion
for warrington uh and uh and warrington
has secured 20 million pounds mr speaker
for new zero emission buses and i'm i'm
delighted to say in a statistic that i
can barely believe but is in your in my
brief 80 of buses in britain's urban
areas are already produced domestically
mr speaker which is which is a fantastic
thing and i hope i hope i know that we
all want to see more of that and i hope
that warrington will consider excellent
uk bus manufacturers when they come to
their next contract
thank you mr speaker yesterday the prime
minister told me that we can sanction
duma members with the government's new
sanctions package
the right honourable member for
braintree told the house that we can
sanction human members not through the
new regime but as an extension of
pre-existing sanction rules yet this
morning the foreign secretary said that
the legislation for sanctions against
yuma members will take weeks to be made
legally watertight so prime minister who
is right how can we say we're standing
strong against russian aggression when
our sanctions response is such a muddle
and such a mess
mr speaker uh i think the whole house
will agree i hope the whole house will
agree that it's quite a thing to
sanction parliamentarians and that is
what we're doing
that is what we're that is what we're
doing and not only that uh we were
putting forward just in the last couple
of days the biggest package of sanctions
against russia that this country has
ever introduced and we're coming forward
with even more and uh they will have an
impact not just on duma members uh
people who vote people who voted uh for
the succession of the oblasts of
dunyensk and luganz they will have an
impact on the entire putin regime and
i'm glad that the labour opposition uh
at least for now supports them
thank you mr speaker this is day six for
thousands of households across east
sussex who have no power and no water as
we become more and more reliant on
electricity we must become more
resilient can ask the prime minister to
ensure that the utility companies work
together that water companies have to
have generators in place so that the
water doesn't fail when the power does
and that local resilience forums are fit
for purpose and communicate with their
local community we need more help on
this prime minister please help us prime
minister i thank him very much for what
he said about people in east sussex and
i just want to say i i know how uh
how tough it is for people who've been
uh short of power for for days on end
and uh it is no consolation to them for
me to say that 97 of uh who lost power
have now been reconnected but we're
working as fast as we can with local
authorities uh with the electricity
companies to make sure that they get
their power back but also ensuring uh
that we build in more resilience for the
future jamie stone
mr speaker let's be quite clear about
this it is not an absolute disgrace
that a privy counselor an adviser to the
queen and a former first minister of
scotland sees fit to broadcast his
half-baked world views
week after week on russian television
mr speaker that was a brilliant powerful
question with which i think the whole
house ascended would it not have been
more powerful if he didn't come from the
leader of the scottish national party
thank you very much thank you very much
mr speaker the prime minister would have
seen
the devastation in shrewsbury of the
flooding of the river seven
this is the third year in the road that
shrewsbury has faced these appalling
floods
i chair the caucus
of 44 conservative mps who have the
river seven britain's longest river
flowing through their constituencies
will he help me and and our caucus to do
everything possible to find a long-term
solution to managing britain's longest
river and in the meantime we have put
forward four opportunities for flood
defenses in shrewsbury to defra would he
please take an interest in these because
shrewsbury cannot afford a fourth year
in a row of flooding
prime minister uh i i thank him very
much for for what he said and he uh and
he's he's completely right in what in uh
what he says about the seven and the the
violence of flooding uh in the seven
which i've seen for myself and seven
area which i've seen for myself uh
several times there are still flood
warnings uh in uh in place along uh the
seven uh mr speaker all i can tell him
is that we are working flat out uh to uh
to put the remediations in place to help
people who have suffered from flooding
but also investing 5.2 billion pounds in
the flood defenses of this country david
the leader in this morning's times is
escaping criticism of the government's
limited sanctions against russia
if the prime minister won't listen to
members of this house would he at least
listen to the times newspaper
prime minister
mr speaker i have the utmost respect for
uh the the media and uh of course i uh
study study as much as i possibly can
but i have to say i think that the
package that the uk uh has put forward
has has been uh has been leading the
world uh and there is there is more to
come and uh mr speaker i hear i hear uh
somebody uh on the opposite benches say
that this is uh this is so far weak it's
not it's going to be it's strong it's
going to be very strong uh something
that would be strong mr speaker would be
to take the whip away from the 14
members of the labour party uh who who
say that the aggressor in ukraine is
nato that would be that would be a
strong thing to do
that's the end of prime minister's
question
point of order bridget phillipson
so that was the prime minister's
questions and we will be discussing that
in a moment but i just want to show you
the scene live now in kiev where the
ukrainian president zelinski is expected
to give a news conference with his
polish and lithuanian counterparts about
the crisis so that's the current scene
there in kiev will of course bring that
to you live as and when that happens so
let's just go to breaking down then
what's happened at uh prime minister's
questions so much happening sam but of
course what dominated was the tensions
between russia and ukraine and the
sanctions that boris johnson so far has
put out against russia
that's right i mean the
tone of today's exchanges actually was a
bit more consensus rather than
confrontation there was clearly concern
on all sides of the house of commons
that perhaps the sanctions regime put
forward by boris johnson doesn't go far
enough boris johnson likes to point out
that 225 people have been sanctioned of
course that's only an increase of three
uh yesterday but there is a sense that
there's more coming from the government
pretty soon uh boris johnson started by
prime minister's questions by saying
that the uk will soon be providing more
help to ukraine he called it lethal aid
and non-lethal aid so the lethal aid
will be perhaps potentially help for
their military the non-lethal age well
separately liz trust has been saying
that they're going to be more uh
availability of uk state-backed loans
essentially for
ukrainian industry to keep that country
functioning but it's uh uh effectively
uh starting to fight a war against uh
russia so i think the impression that
boris johnson wants to give
is of an administration of his
administration really being at the
foothills of responding now quite a lot
of people in the house of commons raised
the point of why
effectively the house of commons uh the
british government was waiting until uh
russia take fur took further action
before uh taking more steps couldn't
they act now to provide some deterrent
rather than waiting uh boris johnson
defended britain as being at the
forefront of the global uh response
let's hear how kierstama and boris
johnson dealt with those points
putin has invaded a sovereign european
nation he is attacked because he fears
openness and democracy
and because he knows that given a choice
people will not choose to live under
erratic violent rule
he seeks division
we must stay united
he hopes for inaction
so we must take a stand
he believes that we're too corrupted to
do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong and i believe
that we can
so will the prime minister work across
the house
to ensure that this is the end of the
era of oligarchic impunity
by saying that this house and this
country will no longer be homes for
their loot
[Music]
mr speaker i don't think any government
could conceivably be doing more to root
out corrupt russian money and that is
that is what uh that is what we are
going to do and i think we can be proud
of what we've already done and the
measures that we have set up and i'm mr
speaker i'm genuinely grateful uh for
the tone of his last question and for
the support and for the support uh he
has given and he is right that it is
absolutely vital that we in the uk
should stand united and people around
the world can see that the uk was the
first to call out what president putin
was doing uh in uh ukraine
and sam the tv station russia today did
feature quite a lot didn't it um kirsten
said that um it's putin's personal
propaganda tool and really pressed the
pm to urge ofcom to look into it because
the responsibility lies with ofcom
doesn't it to do anything about it if at
all that's right this is one of those
developing stories this lunch time uh at
the stroke of midday nadine doris of
course the culture secretary who you'll
have seen in prime minister's questions
released a letter to the media a letter
that she has written today melanie dawes
who's the chief executive of ofcom
essentially calling for exactly what
kierstama uh went on to ask for in the
house of commons chamber uh if we look
at a little bit of that letter it says
it is essential that the uk looks to
limit russia's ability to spread their
propaganda at home i have concerns that
broadcasters such as rt whom ofcom have
found to have repeatedly breached
broadcasting code in the past will also
look to spread harmful disinformation
about the ongoing crisis in ukraine here
in the uk
something rt has previously done in its
biased reporting of the salisbury
poisonings and the conflict in syria so
what you have there is the culture
secretary effectively directing ofcom to
take further action the question is
whether that will be completely to take
that off air
and what are the consequences of that
quite interestingly in the moments after
those exchanges and boris johnson saying
that the cultural sector had taken
action
the conservative mp for high peak robert
largan uh actually jumped in and
responded on twitter to this subject
saying i'd be cautious about banning rt
president putin would respond by banning
the bbc in russia which actually cuts
through his propaganda to millions
meanwhile rt in the uk is ignore ignored
by all but the likes of richard bergen a
reference to the uh jeremy corbyn ally
and labour mp
and there is this sense that boris
johnson has been trying to
fight russian propaganda by boosting
russian language bbc services in parts
of ukraine in order to get
different viewpoints uh over to people
in that part of the world so it is a
delicate discussion it's not the first
time that we've talked about whether or
not
stations like rt should stay on air
action of course taken against press tv
in the past so it wouldn't be
unprecedented uh but i think there is
now clear direction from the secretary
of state uh so it's now over to ofcom uh
to see what happens next that's very
interesting isn't it that the view that
you raised because it's both ways isn't
it you know if the prospects of the bbc
of course being taken away in russia and
then that sort of information that you
get the limited information indeed that
you get do we have any idea at all as to
the direction that ofcom is heading well
i think ofcom have had this letter
probably for about 20 minutes so we'll
have to wait from them uh for the rest
of the day but i think there is a sense
that it's quite complicated uh debate i
mean you'll have to look at whether or
not um rt in the uk is genuinely making
a difference to the to the to the public
debate in fact the issue of artie who
appears on it did come up several times
in prime minister's questions there was
a lot of questions about that former
first minister of scotland alex salmon
who does appear regularly uh on rt and
whether that's appropriate you had uh
questions to the prime minister and he
making his view uh very clear so i think
there is a debate about uh about that to
be had um but i think he's over to
melanie dawes who runs offcom to see
what happens there and how they respond
as to it actually whether the channel is
completely taken off